and there's some events to be held at
Raley library burglar build a will be at
Great Wakering library in the High
Street on the April at 14 between
two-thirty and 4 30 p.m. it's an
afternoon themed around the popular
children's book with plenty of
activities to enjoy if you'd like
further information contact great
wakering library on 0 1 702 219 438
Rochford District Council's recycling
team will be at raley library on the
19th of april at 10am for the baby and
toddler session in the build-up to real
nappy week if you'd like more
information contact 01 268 double 758 30
Mike Davis will be displaying his
collection of historic Raley photos at
as part of local history month at the
library from May the 12 for two weeks
more information on that contact the
library again on Oh 1268 double 75 830
there's a farmers market being held at
great wakering community center the old
school high street great wakering this
is on Saturday April the 16 and
thereafter will be held every third
Saturday of the month until November if
you'd like more information telephone
0170 2218 631 and the some council
meeting dates for you all these that all
these meetings will be held at the Civic
sweet to hockley road Raley ss6 atb they
all begin at seven thirty the review
committee meets on the fifth of April
the standards committee meet on the
seventh of April the audit committee
meet on the twelfth of April the
executive committee meets on the
thirteenth of April the development
committee mates on the fourteenth of
April and the full council meet on the
nineteenth
if you'd like more information about
this contact the member services on 0 1
702 318 140 and rainy horticultural
society spring show of flowers
vegetables floral art and home crafts
will be held on sunday april the third
it is open to the public from 2pm to 430
p.m. and is being held at the mill Arts
& Events Center bellingham lane
admission is one pound for adults and
accompany children of free there's free
parking nearby and if you'd like further
information contact details are on the
society's website at wwlp.com k
if you need to get in touch with the
council here are some numbers for you
the customer services street scene team
0170 2318 one double one they deal with
refuse and recycling bulky household
collections pest control environmental
health pollution noise bonfires food
complaints tree preservation orders
woodlands and trees parks and open
spaces abandoned vehicles stray animals
streetlights and recruitment the
customer services planning and community
team 0170 2318 191 they deal with
planning planning enforcement building
control land charges cemeteries
homelessness housing and leisure
activities the email address customer
services at Rochford gov UK and the
opening hours are 8 30 25 30 monday to
thursday and 8 30 to five on friday for
the automatic payments line for council
tax and parking penalty notices 0207 138
1976 council tax and benefits inquiries
0170 23 18 19 7 or 8 seater SI ta 0170
25 double 3 double 804 missed bins essex
county council highways 0845 60 376 31
for gritting dropped kerbs broken
manhole covers potholes trees on grass
verges Rochford Housing Association
oh-eight-hundred 012 1991 Rochford main
reception switchboard 0 1 702 546
366 rayleigh civic sweet transportation
and hackney carriage office 01 2687 986
double zero and for out-of-hours
emergencies only 01 2685 273 17
rochford District Council has joined a
new scheme which aims to help you make
informed decisions about where to eat
out the council has joined the national
food hygiene rating scheme which
provides customers with information
about hygiene standards at the time of
inspection all food businesses where you
can buy or eat food are listed on the
website ratings docked food guru ke with
their most recent inspection score this
will allow more informed choice in where
to eat as well as encourage food
businesses to improve their hygiene
standards the scheme was developed by
the Food Standards Agency and has been
adopted by other local councils such as
south end and basildon there are six
tiers of the scheme ranging from naught
which means urgent improvement necessary
to five very good the businesses that
have been given a rating are cafes
sandwich shops pubs restaurants
supermarkets and other food retailers
certain premises are exempt which
include roll low risk premises not
generally recognized as food businesses
childminders are also exempt as
inspection businesses are rated on three
elements how hygienic Li the food is
handled prepared cooked cooled reheated
and stored the condition of the
structure of the premises cleanliness
lighting and ventilation how the
business manages and records what it
does to make sure food is safe these
three elements are then calculated to
result in a food hygiene rating the
ratings are then displayed on the
website in addition the businesses have
been given a certificate and window
sticker to display at the premises
speaking at the launch in February
Rochford District Council's portfolio
holder for the environment councillor
Mike steptoe said wherever you want to
eat out you will now be able to find a
wealth of information at the touch of a
button rochford District Council is
looking forward to being part of the
scheme and I'm especially pleased to say
that ninety percent of our
establishments received one of the top 3
ratings
Catriona Stewart head of the food
hygiene ratings team that the FSA said
we are encouraging as many local
authorities as possible to run the
scheme so it's great news that Rochford
District Council are the latest to
announce their intention to use it
around 1 million people suffer from food
poisoning every year and our aim in
introducing the scheme is to reduce this
the ratings will give consumers a
glimpse of what is going on in the
kitchen when they eat out or behind the
scenes that the places they shop before
they make their decision about which
place they should prefer to visit
take pride in the district we want you
to feel good about the area you live and
work in and most people take a great
deal of pride in this district but sadly
it has been noticed that there has been
an increasing problem with dog fouling
and litter throughout the winter months
the council aims to provide a good to
provide good quality streets and open
spaces free from litter and other
environmental crimes and helped to make
Rochford a desirable place in which to
live work or visit you can help your
community by using the street litter
bins town centre ones can collect
recycling wrapping chewing gum in its
original paper and putting it in the
litter bin not throwing your cigarette
butts on the ground use an ashtray
litter bin or an empty cigarette packet
keep your recyclables and
non-recyclables inside the wheelie bin
not parking where you want us to clean
and clear up after your dog it is the
owner's responsibility when a dog fouls
on the street road or grass verges or
park areas it's so important to clean up
after dogs mess because aside from the
unpleasant sight of mess left by son dog
owners dog feces can carry a parasitic
roundworm called Toxocara canis the
dog's feces become contagious two to
three weeks after being deposited and
contact with Toxocara eggs can result in
I disorders stomach upset sore throats
headache asthma and epileptic fits the
best way to avoid Toxocara infestation
is to use a doggie bag or a carrier bag
to pick up the feces preferably this
should be placed in a dog waste bin
found in the district or take the back
home and double wrap it and depositing
your purple lidded waste bin dog feces
attract flies and results in unpleasant
odors so allowing a dog to foul on the
street and not picking it up is an
irresponsible acts
if you have any questions or concerns
about dog fouling in the district you
can contact the council on 0 1 702 318
one double one and do remember it is an
offence not to clear up after your dog
and can result in fines of up to 1,000
pound